وكما
ذكر ولا واحده من هذه المذابح تحلل
اسرائيل من التزامها تجاه القانون ولكنها
ستمكن المحكمه من تقدير ثلاث جوانب اساسيه
في هذه الدعوه الحاليه والتي
اخفاها رافع هذه الدعوه عن الحضور
اوها لو كان هنالك افعال يمكن ان ترقى الى
الاباده الجماعيه فتلك الافعال ارتكبت بحق
اسرائيل لو كان هنالك قلق بشان لتزام
الدول بموجب اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه
فان هذا مرتبط بالمسؤوليه المتعلقه
بالتصرف ضد حماس والذين اعلنوا بفخر عن
اجندته والمتمثله في محو اسرائيل واباده
اليهود وهذا ليس سرا
يخفى ان اللغه العباديه لحماس تكررت مرات
عده على لسان قادتهم
وزعمائهم وفي احد مكاتب
حماس كان هناك حديثا عن اباده قذاره
اليهود ومحوها عن
الوجود وغازي حمد في مقابله مع التلفزيون
اللبناني في ال 2 والذي اشار الى هجمات
السابع من اكتوبر وما تصفه حماس وما تسميه
طوفان
الاقصى
و في تلك المقابله سئل حمد غازي حمد هل
هذا يعني اباده اسرائيل والقضاء عليها قال
نعم بالتاكيد ان وجود اسرائيل هو غير
منطقي غير منطقي ثم تابع قائلا لا احد
ينبغي ان يلومنا على ما نفعله وما نقوم
وما قمنا به في السابع من اكتوبر او
العاشر من اكتوبر او اكتوبر المليون كل ما
نقوم به مبرر
ومسوي الاقتباس على ضوء ما حدث في السابع
من اكتوبر وقبل اي رد عسكري اسرائيلي جنوب
افريقيا اصدرت بيانا رسميا تلوم اسرائيل
فيه
على دد وتلوم اسرائيل على قتل ابنائها
وشعبها وهذا ما توافق عليه يوافق عليها
احد المتقدمين ثانيا ردا على المذابح في
السابع من اكتوبر
والتي توعدت حماس علنا بتكرارها
واسرائيل لها الحق الاصيل في اتخاذ كافه
التدبير المشروعه للدفاع عن مواطنيها
وضمان الافراج عن الرهين هذا
الحق اقرته جميع دول العالم دون شك لكن
المدهش ان المحكمه
طلبت ادخال تدابير احترازيه تطالب اسرائيل
بوقف عملياتها العسكريه او
تعليقها ولكن هذا يرقى الى محاوله لحرمان
اسرائيل من قدرتها للايفاء بالتزاماتها
وتعهداتها المتمثله في الدفاع عن شعبها
والافراج عن واكثر من 11 الا اسرائيلي
نزحوا وشردوا عن بيوتهم وتمكين من العوده
بامان الى بيوتهم ان ان الدوله التي تقدمت
بهذه الدعوه لم تذكر او لم تشر الى
المعاناه
الانسانيه للشعب اليهودي على يد حماس و
وما والمعامله التي يتعرض لها الرهان
مازالوا الذين ما زالوا قيد
الاحتجاز ولكن
هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين هل هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين يظهرون على الشاشه اليسوا جديرين
بالحمايه
حماس حماس ليست طرفا في هذه الاتفاقيه
والطلب المقدم يحاول ان يحرم اسرائيل من
حقها الاصيل في الدفاع عن نفسها و جعل
حماس تفلت من هذه الجريمه وتترك اسرائيل
غير قادره على الدفاع عن نفسها ضد اي
هجمات تستهدفها امس احد
المحامين ذكر ان اسرائيل ستحرم من هذا
الحق وانها لن تكون قادره على الدفاع عن
نفسها ضد هجمات حماس ولكن اود ان الفت
انتباه المحكمه الى هذه الكلمات التي
كتبها
البروفيسور واسب ان مصدر الهجوم سواء من
كان كان من دوله او طرف من غير
الدول لا يحرم حق الطرف الاخر من الدفاع
عن نفسه و لانه لا احد ولا دوله ملزم وفقا
للقانون
ان
يتحمل نتيجه تلك الهجمات
واسرائيل تحترم هذه اذا كان
الدعاء المدعي ان النزاع المسلح بين
اسرائيل وحماس يجب ان تحرم اسرائيل من
حقها في الدفاع وقدرتها على الدفاع عن
شعبها
فان
حجه حجه جنوب افريقيا
و هذه
المحكمه تطلب من المحكمه ان توقف كل
العمليات العسكريه ضد ضد فصيل او منظمه
اجندتها تقوم على الاباده استخدمت كل
الهدن ووقف اطلاق النار لاعاده تسليح
نفسها هذه المنظمه التي اعلنت ان ان
عازمه على تنفيذ اجندتها التي تقوم على
الاباده
و
ثالثا تم اعلام المحكمه باحداث السابعه من
اكتوبر لانه ان كان هنالك اي تدابير
احترازيه ينبغي ان يشار اليها هنا فان تلك
التدابير ينبغي ان تتعلق بجنوب افريقيا
جنوب
افريقيا تتمتع بعلاقات وثيقه مع حماس
برغم تصنيفها كمنظمه ارهابيه من قبل عديد
الدول في العالم هذه العلاقه ما زالت
مستمره حتى بعد احداث السابع من اكتوبر
والمذابح التي شهدها ذاك اليوم جنوب
افريقيا لطالما استضافت واحتفلت بعلاقاتها
مع قاده حماس بما في ذلك وفدا رفيع
المستوى
لحماس زار
الدوله
ل في ملتقا للتضامن بعد اسابيع من ذلك من
تلك المذبحه جنوب
افريقيا ترافعت بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده
الجمعيه
ولكن ينبغي الالتزام بتلك
ال اتفاقيه وان تتوقف عن استخدام اللغه
التي تقوم على نزع المشروعيه عن حماس
وتتوقف عن عن
عن تاييدها لحماس و
بما يفضي الى وقف حماس عن اجنتها وتقوم
بالافراج عن الرهائن